leute wenn ich das dann gewinne ich euch
allen schweizer verlor sich einem eine
playstation 3 hallo ich ein freund und
herzlich willkommen zu einer spontanen
runde hunger games ich habe keine camp
drin und ich spielen mal wieder diese
komische ändern map hier und es geht
auch sofort los und ich bin zurück cool
und sofort schon schwer durch wird zwar
zurück gebracht aber egal ich habe ein
schwert so wenn die unverwundbarkeit an
liest dann wäre die ich sofort auf die
leute drauf gehen das ist eigentlich nur
ganz spontan ohne weil ich ein bisschen
bock drauf hab ihr wolltet ihr ein
bisschen spontane sachen von mir haben
da habt ihr es ich wollte eigentlich
eine trading tipps ich kein schaden ach
so ist einfach unverwundbarkeit jetzt
ende ich wollte eigentlich mal so eine
tolle runde machen wo ich einfach die
leute trolle und das dann als nachher
zusammenstellen ein bisschen
professioneller und den ganzen kram
sache war dann halt nur dass ich da
jetzt eine lange zeit am aufnehmen war
und das ganze dann oh mein gott das ist
ja gar keine richtige orgien töten das
ganze wird viel zu lange dauern das
ganze erstmal aufzunehmen und es gibt
viel zu wenig situationen wo man im
nachhinein auch sagen kann haye den habe
ich ja geträumt weil dann irgendwie
solche sachen wie wir in einem tempel
war oder so das habe ich eine szene
hingekriegt
da war in einem tempel und ich hab mich
die ganze band verstecken gesagt habe
ich und dann bin ich da vor hingegangen
so was alles also so was halt verstehe
ich unter trollen hat da nicht so
funktioniert wie ich mir das vorgestellt
arbeitet als relativ lange gedauert hat
das ganze aufzuziehen zu machen etc
hier seine trainerin würde
deswegen wollte ich euch jetzt ganz
stimmt einfach mal fragen ob ihr denken
vorschlag hätte wie ich das eventuell
aufziehen könnte was ihr euch da
wünschen würde oder allgemein neue
serien ideen in minecraft kann ja sein
dass ihr da irgendwie sagt soja macht ob
man dies macht man das hier das eine
gute idee sondern wieder trifft er mich
aber ich ihn fast nie habe ich auf jeden
fall achten von juristen gehabt ok
schuhe habe ich auch schon gut also wenn
ihr ideen habt dann könnt ihr mir das
einfach unten in die kommentare
schreiben
die träume oder so hätte ich echt bock
dran ich habe mir nämlich letztes
battlefield throl videos geguckt da geht
das sehr gut weil er kämpfen viele leute
kann sich eine strategie stellen ihnen
die c4 werfen die sowas klappt jetzt
jetzt zurzeit noch nicht so toll ja
keine ahnung muss man einfach gucken
vielleicht kann ich das auch beim 1 war
irgendwie machen also wenn die ideen
habt hier ist ein aufruf wenn ihr die
habt dann könnt ihr mir die einfach
senden bzw nicht vorschreiben tief
hinter mir
der wird von den anderen typen da noch
attackiert ja da läuft ein anderer typ
hinter dem hinterher doch mal geht's auf
den diesel läuft erhält doch endlich
meinen namen geändert kommt die menschen
es geht soll das ist ein richtiges
gemälde du fröhliche drauf gesprungen
bin war schneller als ich hab mich
natürlich langsam an den spaß mit pfeil
nach mir geschossen
das sind hier mit diamant ist sie auch
noch hinter mir kommen entschied sich
jetzt für einen gehst auf den will ich
auch nicht gehen
der diamant sachen wie sachen die alle
die am anzahl ist gar nichts ok es fast
keiner mehr hinter mir dass meine chance
sich von 14 wie verstecken bzw versuche
ich jetzt hier oben einfach mal dass ich
hoffe ok falsch kauft jetzt lover hier
kann ich mich dahinter verstecken
kommt hoch doch nicht okay das wäre ich
wahrscheinlich nicht ok schade ist jetzt
aber geht es fast schon wieder los
die wiese 2 in einem das ist irgendwie
komisch ich bin jetzt fand die bahn die
93 als ich mir jetzt einfach mal direkt
weiter auf kernkraft endlich meine geht
vielleicht weil ich das ganze auch mcp
vp machen das sind diese maps wo das so
alles riesig ist und wo man teilweise
nur 50 minuten 100 dass ich dann einfach
so die trotzdem raus schneide
also dass sich einerseits die runde so
ge hochladen als 30 40 minuten runde und
dann noch mal die ganzen trolls frau
schneider also das damals troll touch
vogler nicht weil das trio games toll
games müssen einfach gucken nimmt also
wenn ihr den ob einfach in die
kommentare schreiben
ich weiß das kommt sehr einig so was
auch schon alle machen aber meinst noch
mal anders und wir sind hier alle
professional suite als auf englisch wir
professional suite die information
so also wir stehlen von uns nicht
gegenseitig sondern wir uns
inspirationen versuchen auf unserer
besser zu machen so genau warum werde
ich ihn mal zurück gepackt mich das
antrittsalter die ganze zeit egal die
map habe ich schon mal gespielt deswegen
weiß ich dass ich in dieses dorf rein
muss wir sind auf jeden fall ne menge
kisten packen ich lauf komplett falsche
richtung egal
kommt schon bitte lass mich ihren neuen
hit jetzt nicht auf das ist ja auch noch
vor mir da hinten in dem tempo
okay da vorne rein ich jetzt da unten
rein da unten kann ich nämlich nicht
rein weil das wurde bei wie hey gesperrt
das da unten weil allerdings kannten wie
man da unten rein kommt oder aus
irgendwelchen anderen gründen ich weiß
es nicht ich versuche hier allerdings
jetzt einfach mal rein zu kommen
also ich hoffe mal dass ich da reingehen
kann wir gehen erst einmal die war doch
irgendwie so ein baum hier auf jeden
fall einen baum
hallo
jeder baum ist weg kein plan wie ich da
rein komme kann ich da gar nicht allein
oder wie die einfach so ein eingang
eingebaut
mehr geht wohl nicht auf fakt ist ich
dachte kreierte kisten oder so nach man
nicht so gar nichts wenn wir am start
wieder zurückgesetzt wurde jetzt bis
mich schwer sein ist einfach immer so
ich will immer am start einfach
zurückgesetzt also letzte mal gab es da
eine kiste
jetzt aber gar nicht versuche ich mir
einfach hier weiter zu laufen da hinten
links müsste das dorf sein
ich glaube ich glaube wieder so ein
bisschen hier so durch die pampa weil
bei ihr nach runde mal zusammen mit
denen habe ich hier sachen gefunden das
war dann ganz cool ist aber keiner
hinter mir dass kunden das ist ein
schönes screenshot wehrt euch schon
jetzt hoch warum sind ob sie dir gott
ich hasse schwimme ich hasse schwimmen
minecraft dass meine versuche unendlich
langsam nehmen ich meine ein echtes ist
ja auch so dass wenn man auftaucht dass
man deutlich schneller als wenn man wenn
man auftaucht und hochschulen bis man
deutlich schneller als wenn man unter
1000 hier ist man einfach beim
untertauchen viel schneller
und jetzt hier hin wenn du sachen
braucht sagt bescheiden ja ich brauche
sachen aber ich sage nicht nein weil ich
das selber hinkriegen
euro auch das nun tintenfisch händen
haben mensch des griechischen partner
habe auch gleich richtig hunger dann
verliere ich auch sogar noch leben
ich brauche definitiv jetzt irgendwas zu
essen auch wenn es nur ein schwein ist
so ein kotelett geht auch immer und ich
bin ein richtiger typ und sprinter so
war denn jetzt dieser tempel da das an
ein tempel nicht das haus meinig
dass das haus da ne kiste hinter das
weiß ich noch
dass das haus hier überhaupt kein plan
egal ich schaue ich glaube nicht aber
was ist das doch hier ist es so kisten
kästen gis dem kies der im ersten teil
kaputt machen ich brachte gießt in denen
ich ihn brauche doch andere eine kiste
mit irgendwas dran ort jetzt habe ich
drei dings gleich von der ich leben
durch mich durch bestellen
wir sind echt gar keine kisten ist doch
hier an sich
ich habe selbst ligna sprinten kann ja
nie mehr
ich glaube jetzt einfach weiterhin die
richtung dass der sonne
daher gilt kribl abwehr oder drei leute
schon getötet wird wahrscheinlich anfang
glück ab und wurde nicht zurückgelegt
ist hier obsidian mein gott da oder war
das war das haus genau
und hier war die kiste da war die
nächsten typen getötet das weiß ich noch
in der alten runde
und da bin ich hier lang gegangen aber
ihren kissen das weiß ich noch genau ich
das mal rein und zwar ohne fledermaus
stirbt regal kommt an hoch und eine
kiste und hat sie auch gerne versteckt
aber den euch dann zum glück getötet und
ich glaube da kommt auch wieder an tüten
jedoch nicht dass norderstedt
ich hab den chats übrigens mal anders
eingestellt ich hoffe euch mundet dieser
einstellung geht gar nix ellmann
wichtig ist echt nix wie weg komme ich
hatte dich spanisch mitteln krippl
verließ die arena getötet
na gut dann tschüss sale so ich muss nur
an ihnen die kiste daran kommen sonst
breche auch heute wenn ich das dann
gewinne ich euch einen schmatzer und
verlor sich eine playstation 3 drückt
mir nie darum post auf jeden fall
schauen was zu essen ich verlost 2 ps3
wenn ich das gewinnen jetzt gewinne ich
das bestimmt auch noch wenig davon ist
es doch das wird auch schon total
ausgeraubt seien auch schon total aus
kanada hat dieser saturn da kann ich
leider kann ich noch mal schauen
aber da sehe ich an das wird
wahrscheinlich mein unternehmen
ja der ist da drin weil dahinter weise
nicht
der eine kiste endlich sie ist leer
es ist doch so ganz ich es ist doch wo
soll ich jetzt meine teppich ich komme
auch immer selber wäre
wir sind doch studio kommt dass noch
eine kugel gibt kann ich nur ein
bisschen was abklopfen
es ist ein kissen er stört sich auch
schon da ist sie dann typen wie dich ja
man drei robbie oder müssen nicht nur
besser es hat mich gesehen
ich wünsche
ok ich kann nicht richtig schreiben will
naja so spät abends gut 10 uhr aber ich
weiß nicht ob meine schwester schon
paint oder so deswegen eine silent ohne
also wie gesagt wenn ich dir vergessen
habt schreibt in die kommentare wenn die
idee noch zum trollen oder sowas denkt
wie vor bock drauf aber minecraft nicht
auch hier war noch mal ein paar kisten
einfach wenn ich jetzt den schwerpunkten
rüstungsteile finden würde will ich noch
mal ein bisschen motivation schöpfen wir
noch ein bisschen mit elan weiter zu
spielen dass eventuelle alles zu
schaukeln werde ich aber wahrscheinlich
nicht dass du die doofe sache dann
gleich jetzt auch schon wieder nacht
glaube ich oder das sonntagnacht regel
rhythmus teil pups ich weiß nicht alle
sein
sonntagnacht regel rhythmus hat
natürlich nicht jeder server also ich
kann die rückzahlung ist ein jump'n'run
com sanyo durch versuchen noch einmal
wenn ich dann sterben
okay soweit bin ich schon mal gekommen
und wohnen jetzt wieder runter oder wie
wir schreiben jetzt genau ist der moment
wo alle wieder die container herum waren
kind ich hab es nicht gefunden
vielleicht ist hier im wald irgendwo
eine kiste nein das ist gome durch
versteckte doch in den kisten wald ich
versuche einfach so lange zu überleben
wie es geht aber ich kann nichts
versprechen
da oben war der großen tournee nicht
eingehen wollte bzw
dies schloss die spieler ja komm
nein okay das ist mein tod
jetzt gleicht immer mehr sprinten
ok just died for some reason
ich weiß gibt keine ahnung wovon ich
gestorben bin aber noch gut
ich würde die schützen der beschreibung
facebook twitter steht eine beschreibung
wenn ideen habt zu trollen
beziehungsweise allgemeinen projekten in
minecraft können jetzt auch eine
beschreibung schreiben und dann will ich
sagen beschreibung beschreiben
beschreiben bis zum nächsten mal wenn es
euch gefallen es gibt einen daumen hoch
wir sind beim nächsten mal beschreibung
beschreibung beschreiben facebook
twitter ideen